(wind)
[Conan] And oh, $9000.
[Aaron] Oh sweet. Great.
(wind)
(whistling)
(background noise)
Okay, 360 Live, here's the latest.
I am, well God knows where I am.
I honestly don't know.
I'm at an airfield about an hour
from our studio at Warner Brothers.
And we are going to shoot the portion
of the cold open where I'm stranded
by Andy Richter, and I have
no way to get to Comic Con.
So what I do is I find
an old World War I plane
and I fly it, which
will then take us nicely
into a segment of a very popular movie.
That's all I gotta say.
Maybe this airs after you've
already seen the cold open.
So you know that it's Wonder Woman.
So I shouldn't even be coy.
But anyway, here we are.
This is a 1929 Travel Air,
sort of the Cessna of its day.
That's a Curtiss-Wright engine,
this is a two-seater plane.
And I'll be pretending to fly it.
I don't really fly a plane, but
I like to know about things.
I think that's all I have for now.
And watch this
(laughing)
Yeah, that was cool.
(wind)
We'll never see the shot
It's not good if we have to match it.
We're creating our own
Yeah
You're, but you're gonna see that, you're
We're maybe taking the same shot
and putting our plane
Right.
over their plane.
Exactly. Yes.
We're like wiping out their plane.
And then ours will crash into the
Sea.
Yes.
Will Gal Gadot see me crash
or no ...?
No
[Man] Still speeding
[Conan] And say action!
[Todd] And action
(sound of car passing)
(background noise)
(train whistle)
[Todd] Trains, planes, and automobiles.
[Director] Let's cut guys.
[Conan] There's a zeppelin coming through!
[Jason] That's great. Now what?
(upbeat music)
[Sona] What?
[Conan] I would never do this.
[Kramer] But if you're
looking at it you're
I'm an aviator...I'm the one who knows.
[Conan] I'd like the person
who's flying my plane
to actually have a skeletal structure.
Why do you tape this garbage?
Because I'm employed.
(woman laughs)
what do you mean?
(upbeat music)
(propeller noise)
[Conan] Are we getting this on 360?
Oh good, you got it.
I thought you were just holding